an overhaul was needed but getting it
was tough reform taking years and
Parliament bearing the brunt of many
angry protests the endgame is now
finally here Monday so vote on the final
package of reforms by the agricultural
committee expectations were high we're
very much looking forward to see commack
reebok in favor of the whole CIP package
the farmer is waiting for the you to
make a decision on future the CAAP and
in this respect it is of paramount
importance to have the decision out in
order to make farmers to their
investment than planning for the future
years they need this information myself
I'm a farmer and I leave South of France
so I'm here today I'm really expecting
maybe kind of surprise let's see em ep's
were also divided the Greens an ECR
group had joined hands to criticize
erosion of greeting principles for them
countries have been given funding
options that in fact meant that the
so-called greening and rural development
under c.a.p would be lost so in reality
not much would change time to get down
to business so what's the result where
the big majority the CIP reform package
was adopted relief the wrangling was
over we certainly welcome the positive
vote of kamagra today it's a clear sign
that kamagra members understand the
importance of this decision to European
farmers and their cooperatives the
unbalanced situation remains of course
the small minorities is happy because
there will be no change or very little
change and for the Greens the policy was
simply a green wash forgiveness vaginas
the flawless nominee Longstaff indian
does man in the scene [ __ ] definitely
final another copy to chaos clumped but
a concession by one of the authors of
the reform package their son saha
complet mon-sat is fair my imaginary
part sukin on the Congress a and Company
équilibre but me to lay perspective a
final vote on CA piriform is expected at
the plenary in November or December